hi today I'm gonna show you how to get a
modeling job I am Daniel Maritz and this
is the DLM model lifestyle
okay so how do you get a modeling job?
well first you need to get a modeling
agency if you want to know how to get a
model agency then check out my video on
how to get a modeling agency.
now you
will also need a model portfolio which
is a book of your best model photos in
them check out my video on how to get a
model portfolio but let's say you have a
model agency and a model portfolio there
are two ways to get modeling jobs you
get the jobs through going to castings
the other way is through direct bookings
so what is a casting well the casting is
like a job interview
your agency will
send you to meet with a client when you
get there
you will show them your model portfolio
and they will go through your pictures
if they like you and your model
portfolio then they might ask you to
change into their clothes and also take
some pictures they do this for two
reasons first they need to see how their
clothes fit on you and second they need
to see how you would pose so that they
know how you would perform on the day of the photo shoot
in this market we have
to go to castings with Booker's in a van
we cannot go to the castings by
ourselves
because we cannot speak their language
you also need to prepare yourself for
the competition that you will encounter
there are a lot of models going for a
casting and they are all competing for
the same job let's say your agency has
five models that go to the casting but
there are 10 agencies in the whole
market that means your competition is
around 50 models and they all want the
same job
now when the clients have seen
all the models they will choose the
model that they like the most if they
like your personality your modeling
portfolio how the clothes fit on you and
your poses then you might book the job
the clients will then contact your model
agency and set up a date for the
modeling job and that is it you are
booked
now the second way to get booked
for a modeling job is through direct
bookings now how do direct bookings work?
well the client books you for the job
just from seeing your photos online or
they have worked with you before and want
to use you again
you do not need to do a
casting for direct bookings they just
booked you directly from the agency
because they like you
now direct bookings
can also be international for example
you might live in South Africa like I do
and then the client contacts your model
agency to book you for a job in Thailand
the client will normally pay for your
flight your accommodation and all the
other expenses in your time there
so what kinds of modeling jobs are there
well let me explain some of the basic
jobs there are photoshoots TV
commercials
campaigns
fashion shows showrooms and events now
some people have asked can I get a
modeling job without an agency? well the
short answer is yes but it is extremely
difficult if you are a new model
some models have been modeling for years with
different model agencies so they know
the clients already but I would suggest
not to try this at all because you do
not know who you can trust
this is especially dangerous for girls
there are a lot of weird and dangerous
people out there so be very careful get a
good modeling agency that you can trust
to send you the castings and direct
bookings that is the best way to get
good quality modeling jobs now now if
you want to know more about modeling
check out my ebook down in the
description
alright so now you know how
to get a modeling job
if you liked the
video please subscribe and I'll see you
in the next video